tras más de siete horas de espera en el
aeropuerto para poder acceder a la
ciudad de cali la cual ha tenido durante
toda la jornada sus accesos cerrados la
imagen que nos hemos encontrado al
entrar es la de una una situación de
después de una batalla una imagen que
puede dar titulares pero sin embargo
dista de la realidad ya que la mayoría
de marchas en colombia han sido de
carácter pacífico un pacifismo que
precisamente no es el que las
organizaciones sociales recogen de la
actividad de la fuerza policial y es que
en 97 organizaciones sociales han
denunciado a la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos abusos entre los que
estarían muertes y también llegarían a
ver abusos sexuales y es que desde que
empezó el miércoles el paro nacional de
colombia contra la reforma tributaria
del gobierno demandó que cada vez hay
reportadas más muertes y algunas
organizaciones contaría hasta decenas la
respuesta del gobierno a estas protestas
ha sido el anuncio del sábado 1 de mayo
del gobierno de iván duque de
militarizar las ciudades que presenten
más desmanes en colaboración con
gobernaciones y alcaldías sin embargo
esto no ha gustado a jose miguel vivanco
director para las américas de human
rigth watch quien ha avisado del peligro
de poder
a la fuerza pública al ejército en este
caso en las calles